coming to america is available to stream
today only on amazon prime video eddie
murphy and arsenio hall
are back and the heir to the throne
of the good royal country of zumunda
is played by the actor and comedian
jermaine fowler who joins us here on the
rich eisen show how are you jermaine
i'm good man how are you damn straight
you're good what a gig this is
i know i know you're telling dude it's
awesome
i mean so um when did you first see the
original
do you have a memory of when you first
saw the original jermaine
yeah uh yeah i do um i first saw it
probably i was nine
uh nine or eight maybe ten you know uh
it was
always playing around my house then i
just snuck
in the living room uh put the vhs tape
in and
washed it and fell in love well i mean
you know um obviously getting into a
role
and needing to look at somebody that
you're playing with
as royalty might be tough but not i
guess when it's eddie murphy
right exactly dude i mean yeah man
that's royalty
that you that you were hooking up with
how did you learn that you were up for
this and go about the process of getting
this gig
jermaine uh you know just like any other
actor auditioned for roe um i went in
um read the lines for uh craig craig
brewer
and uh he was the best like person i've
ever
you know red lines for in the room he's
the uh
chillest uh most patient director i've
ever been around
and uh you know i didn't think i get the
role but when i walked out of there i
was confident that me and craig would do
something together
um just because he hit it off so well
right and then um i found out that i
you know i got the role from um boo to
riley uh the director
sorry to bother you and um he told me
because he was at the all black film
festival in miami
and uh the producers were down there
talking about my audition
and uh he just had the scoop before my
managers and agents at the time
which was crazy so that's how i found
out and uh what was your first
conversation with eddie murphy like
jeremy uh my first conversation with
eddie was at his house like a couple
years ago actually we
we hung out you know um at his crib um
um numerous times before we even you
know really got to work together
um you know yeah so it was like we
already kind of had a rapport uh me and
his son we write together
um he's a really good writer his name is
mile and uh
you know sometimes you know eddie would
show up and
you know hang out in the living room or
the kitchen and just watch tv with us
and we just talked about
random you know oh excuse me no worries
so when you when you were there if i
told you after the first time that you
were
uh riding with with miles and
uh maybe leaving the murphy mance for
the first time if i'd met you
as you're heading to your car hey guess
what you're going to play his son
in the sequel to coming to america
eddie's not only going to do it
but he's going to do it with arsenio
hall and john amos and james earl jones
and you're going to play his son what
would you have told me if i told you
that
uh i believe you i love it
um it's crazy uh it's you know
my mom has always kind of prepared me
for this moment
when i was younger my mom would always
have me um practice my autograph
when i was a kid um to practice it you
know when i was a little kid because
she knew i wanted to be an actor and she
wanted her kids to be successful she
knew
that practicing your autograph was just
like the first step in just
you know solidifying your identity and
you know your confidence and
you know in yourself and what you do and
um
i got into acting because of eddie you
know i wanted to be an actor because of
him
um i wanted to make movies at a very
early age and he's definitely one of the
reasons why
so i definitely was a very confident
obnoxious dude
when i was younger i worked with eddie
one day i work with any one day
and um here i am man i would have
definitely believed you if you told me
that jermaine fowler here on the rich
eisen show
how close is your mom to uh the leslie
jones is
any similarities because she plays your
mom in the film anything
not at all my mom my mom is tall though
my mom was calling my
dad so my dad was a little
self-conscious about that but my mom was
tall
uh eddie and excuse me leslie and my mom
are complete
opposites but the the one similar they
have is that they don't
care what people think about them okay
um they they own a room
she commands your respect and your
attention when she walks in the room and
she is hilarious my mom is the funniest
person
um that i've probably ever known so she
doesn't she doesn't record
msnbc and yell at the screen and put it
on twitter
like leslie jones your mom doesn't do
that
no it does you did not my mom didn't do
that
she mostly just drank wine and painted
okay very good
i love it very good she was pretty cute
nah that's not my mom
she is funny leslie jones is funny funny
funny funny funny i mean i know you who
you tell yeah man she's
she's awesome man it's a pleasure
working with her and tracy man there's
two people i've really seen morgan
that's rhyming tracy morgan in this
wesley snipes in this
as well john amos you want to talk about
uh royalty
as well uh who was the easiest on the
set to crack up
jermaine are the easiest yeah uh i would
say
the easiest to crack up on set was
probably
i think it's leslie like i think it's
leslie because she just
has this infectious energy about it like
you know we had a good time together
like our job was to be mom and son
yes and so i really had a good time with
her we just we made each other laugh she
made me laugh the most
uh arsenio would sometimes whisper in my
ear of jokes
before we would do a take and you know i
had to hold it together because he just
knows
he just artheno's hilarious and then you
got tracy who's just a character and
you know what i mean like everybody just
is funny you know you got lunell and
rodney perry like the the cast is a
stack for the comedian too you just
can't keep the straight face sometimes
when you're around
jermaine fowler here on the rich eisen
show so what was it like uh around the
set
uh in downtime or did you shoot this
during covert or is this before the
pandemic or
oh no thank god we did we shot this way
before kovit
2019 late 2019 and uh
you know we were it was it was a
different time then no i know
so that's why that's why i ask cause i'd
love to see what it was like around the
set
you know when you're just hanging out
with all of these folks
it was a very beautiful atmosphere um
eddie really invited such a
loving caring welcoming atmosphere and
he's just a great guy
on and off set so he dictated that you
know um he's a great guy
and um it was wonderful to be there man
everybody just went it was like a party
it's like a family reunion to be real
i love that you know i uh here's what i
would have done i don't know if this is
professional or not but i would have
gone up to james earl jones and asked
him to record the outgoing message on my
cell phone
i would see they shot uh james's parts
in new york that's where he lived
you know 90s i believe so yeah he ain't
gonna fly down to atlanta so they went
to james because he was royalty you know
he said you guys come to me and uh they
went to james at the scenes
and that's all good james jones is like
you don't even know he's in new york
doing his part like it feels like you
he's with everybody else
and he's such a powerful presence
in this move in any movie but in this
one it really just added so much depth
um and gravity when he would just speak
and oh god he's just so
perfect um but yeah man uh i would have
loved to have met him and uh but i
didn't i didn't i didn't get to i didn't
get to unfortunately
well congrats on everything jermaine um
what do you want people to know about
this
because um you know it's just it's just
hitting right now and
um you know i know there's tons of
cameos personally i'm hoping that there
is a barbershop scene at the end that's
really long um and uh
what do you want people to know about
this jeremy i want them to know that we
had a great time filming it uh we're so
proud of it and it's a worthy
predecessor to the original
um i think they're gonna love uh the uh
there's just the elements of nostalgia
and the cameos eddie's
it's eddie man eddie who who wouldn't
want to watch eddie be funny
who wouldn't so there's batman so go
enjoy the film with your family and
friends and just have a good laugh we
all need it
all right and if you could choose one
eddie murphy stand up what would you do
what what would you have jermaine uh you
mean picking a special which one
yes which special i think i know which
one it would be but uh
and and give me the give me the special
and and the and the
and the bit from the first okay okay
give me which one
you would choose and the special that
got me in comedy is definitely uh
it's definitely raw wrong okay yeah
that's just special
and uh my business always made me laugh
with the rocky [ __ ]
rocco always made me laugh
see i would i would i would go delirious
that's my
that's my eddie murphy go-to is the the
delirious but delir you can't you can't
go
wrong choosing either one of them man i
mean either one of them delirious
listen delirious is my favorite one this
is raw got me into it because i thought
first you know but that's all delirious
and that one i mean that's
my favorite bit and delirious got to be
um
um i gotta be the singer [ __ ] about um
jermaine stop teasing
like that's probably one of my favorites
well i i appreciate you choosing a clean
one
i'm just holding my breath you know the
honeymooners and everything uh okay
so um before i let you go i'm told
you're a big mma fan do you have any
thoughts on the upcoming weekend's
slate i got some predictions dude um
it's going to be a great card i'm really
impressed by the card uh
even the undercard i think um i'm gonna
start with islam and dover
uh i gotta go with islam but dover is
gonna be a good fight i think i mean it
might be fighting tonight
to be honest um i think every fight's
gonna go by pretty quickly
um i think al jamaine i want alex manuel
uh i like algerman i thought his fight
with uh corey sanhedrin was amazing
uh and corey's great too uh he might be
coming back uh right after those two
amazing wins um some of the alger main
over p uh toyon
okay and then you got uh well you got
amanda nunez versus
megan anderson yes i'm gonna go i gotta
go amanda because
i just because what she did that cyborg
was insane like i've never seen cyborg
take that much damage like that before
so
i think he's going to the same thing the
negan but it's going to be a tough fight
i think
too i think i think it's going to be a
tough fight negan's dope
have you ever thought of doing it
yourself yeah man my dad taught me how
to fight when i was four
and um i got older you know i never
liked to fight but i didn't mind it
because of where i was from
okay um now you always had to stand up
for yourself when i moved to l.a i got
into jiu jitsu uh i cloned gracie's gym
in culver city and
then um i got kickboxing but i'll always
love boxing always in mma i love it in
may but kung fu i taught myself kung fu
when i was like
in eighth grade what did you talk what
do you mean you taught yourself kung fu
jermaine i mean it don't sound strange
but you go to the library and uh pick up
kung fu books
and uh just read them and learn the
stances
in my in my bedroom and uh because i was
training to kick my dad's ass
that's what i was training this week
okay so yeah yeah all right but you know
and i gotta go
um i i might i think i gotta
i think polish power might win
uh might win by tomorrow night i think
uh
i think john might might pull it off
what do you think tj my he's my ufc
259 expert what do you think of these
choices tj i like his choices i think
he's pretty spot on i'm i'm literally
you know i'm kind of torn with the yawn
israel fight
uh i know that's a tough one i have a
hard time betting against izzy
um even though he's going up oh you
should you should
that was a tough decision for me too i
didn't like but every time i sing izzy
like
you know every time izzy faces like you
know a power guy
what does he do he upsets him you know
so i can you can pick izzy like it's i
think it's fine
my only issue is he's going up in weight
that's it
you know and yawn isn't a joke like
people sleep on yawn too like everyone's
doubted yawn
since he you know since the beginning
and look at him now so
izzy could be in coming to america three
i'll tell you that that guy
he is hilarious yeah he's funny by the
way he is he is laugh out loud hilarious
i like izzy man this is dope he'd be a
dope i think he'd be great to have him
if they do a third one i think he's i
would love to
okay i'd love to do a thing with him
well i'll be great that'd be awesome
well yeah
i don't know did you ever talk ufc with
judd hirsch on the set of superior
donuts i think not that's why you come
on
but judge judge a
like if you get on bad side he might
slap you like
i love that he's from new york just from
new york baby you don't mess him in new
york but
i think he's from brooklyn or the bronx
so
fantastic well you've had a hell of a
career so far good luck uh
moving forward come back on the show
anytime and i can't wait
to uh catch coming to america uh as soon
as i'm able thanks for the call
appreciate it you made
that was a pleasure thank you for having
me right back at you jermaine fowler
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here